maire darling I hope you didn't mind
that I jumped in like that well sounds
so good that I had to get in on it
Mariah Carey totally surprised the cast
of shits Creek by crashing their class
of 2020 commencement video here's what
went down the cast of the hit comedy
which ended in April got back in
character for YouTube's dear class of
2020 virtual commencement celebration
Emily hi I'm here we're all here and
we're and ready to go David everyone can
hear you epic right well it got even
better the cast harmonized like whoa
singing Mariah Carey's hit hero that's
when the Grammy winner unexpectedly
joined in and brought it home
[Music]
he will please note the windblown hair
indoors anyway Catherine O'Hara Annie
Murphy Eugene Levy Emily Hampshire and
the rest of the cast looked totally
shook but none more than Dan levy aka
David rose and David feeling like that
it
yes Mariah Carey you'll always be a part
of me and just when you thought it
couldn't get any cuter in enters
Mariah's nine year old twins Moroccan
and Monroe of course fans of the show no
Mariah is a running theme on shits Creek
I don't want to add more stress to your
day but I love you you know that I've
never said that to anyone else aside
from my parents twice and one time I had
a riot Carrey concert I know like when
Patrick fell in love with David and told
him this you're my Mariah Carey that
compliment could bring me to tears but
I'm not gonna let up when that episode
aired in 2018 dan tweeted that he never
thought that line would see the light of
day adding that miracles happen well
Mariah responded that she was laughing
out loud and Dan lost his mind writing
oh my god it's festive
then when Mariah told her Twitter
followers to watch the show in 2019 Dan
lost it again
tweeting when Mariah Carey ends your
life on Valentine's Day it's a
particularly meaningful thing for me
because as a young child she was
everything to me I know her entire
catalog there were posters on the wall
it was a whole thing a few days later he
talked about the whole exchange on The
Late Show with Stephen Colbert thank you
so much for joining our little show
it's a full-circle moment for me and I
think you know sometimes in your in my
short-lived career it's very wonderful
to have these full circle moments but
the magical Moriah moments didn't stop
there yes darling when the series finale
aired in April fans got to see Patrick
and David say I do it will always be a
part of me now I'm part of you
indefinitely boy don't you know you
can't escape me because you know you'll
always be my babies naturally Mariah had
something to say about it
tweeting spoilers but oMG with a bunch
of sobbing face emojis
[Music]